se state cercando una storia che
rispecchi i valori quali l'amore il
rispetto la realtà e l'onestà cambiate e
pure cane dopo però di pensare
avrei voluto essere padre migliore e
pericolosità eccezionale ti si è
mantenuto così giovane come sapete è
così bella e femminile figlia mia
smettila di piangere no scusa che mentre
qualcosa
nell'occhio cento detto che privato il
movente è un pezzo che per lucca nero
che abbandona school mi trovo
ciao
buongiorno benvenuto all'altro mondo
cresce qualcosa da bere nell'attesa un
bicchiere d'acqua
purtroppo a disposizione solo red bull e
cola del todis niente un momento solo
[Musica]
pronto e l'altro dice che vi parla di
temi pure e i santi sono io potevi dirlo
avremo only one si sentì bando le ciance
e arrivato un nuovo qui è un po strano
farmi control una di loro
no oggi ne sono scappati troppi se non
c'è proprio modo guarda papà armando
nimei lanari e jazz e per un po che si
può fare grazie tanto fammi provare
sotto inverno fiammeggiante di temi sono
marco un posto per una persona di
ritrovarmelo mi dispiace ma al momento
non posso controllare oman perché di
santana star techno con charles manson e
sono abbastanza
come dire impegnati poi scusate un
attimo con una chiamata inattesa è
pronto che mi hanno risposto oh ma che
si sente no da quanto tempo ma come stai
bene grazie un po statico che piacere
sentirti madre teresa mi chiede sempre
saluto nata altro ragazzi un secondo
solo gentilmente allora mi sta dicendo
si dicono che è tutto pieno ma che butta
potrebbe ospitarlo nel caso in cui cambi
religione o ok
chiedo un secondo scusi lei non vedo
nessun altro
i posti sono pieni ma nel caso in cui
cambi religioni ci si potrebbe trovare
un compromesso
ah capisco è un peccato avrebbe potuto
chiedere il pacchetto d'anna due amici
insieme a te non ci sarebbero stati
problemi
lasciamo stare allora senti ma nel caso
in cui il tipo non accetti ma in quel
caso si è posto di merda